so
hey everyone
um thanks for having me here today it's
really fun to talk to this crowd i uh
i did a very similar set of slides to
this with this like big
b2b enterprise
company i think two weeks ago like half
the people engineering managers came in
flew in from the east coast they're all
wearing like jackets and ties and the
room really couldn't be more different
than this one but i'm gonna ask you the
same question that i asked them how many
people in here know what airbnb is
okay i'm pretty sure that was everybody
who was able to raise a hand because
they weren't holding a board or
something
but this other one i think about 25 of
the rooms hands went up so i spent the
first time in the presentation just
trying you know explaining what it is
that we do
i'm glad you guys are familiar
um
let's see if i can get this door all
right so i'm actually i'm gonna cover
like three general areas today and then
i think i've got probably like 25
minutes to slide something like that
i'm going to talk a little bit i've
worked with a bunch of different
companies and i think i've got a little
bit to share on culture and what that
means at these different places and how
it affected me working there
i thought that might be interesting for
you since you're at the beginning of
lots of companies
um
33 of them i'm told
and then i'll talk a bit about airbnb's
growth so a little bit about how it's
grown internationally
give you some visualization on that and
some thoughts about why it's grown and
then we'll talk about payments at the
end and you know after that i want this
to be pretty interactive so if you have
questions for me at any time just like
shoot and i'll do my best to answer
do you want them
oh it's a clicker all right
thanks man
cool
which one do i push the next one
oh there we go all right
so i put this together like i'm like
three weeks ago and i was totally blown
away by this but
i've worked in a lot of different
companies um
strangely like almost all of them with
blue logos i think i'm like really into
companies with blue logos
um but this is like a pretty you know
wide range of of tech contains i've been
up before um you guys are probably
familiar with all of them i assume
everybody remembers alta vista back in
the day
right
so i'm just going to talk a bit about
like
um the differences between those
companies so
um
so far
i've been in airbnb for about nine
months before that i was at facebook for
two years before that i was at yava for
a long time leading the mail team
on the
mail team and one of the things that i
learned from that is that
um
vision like from all these companies is
that having a vision is really really
key to being successful ultimately into
having a good culture and i know that
probably actually sounds like really
obvious to this crowd you probably have
heard a lot about like having vision and
culture i was presented this company the
other day and they're like well what if
you're a company that doesn't have a
vision
one of the questions um
so i think the way i think about this is
that
uh
you have to reinforce why you come to
work every single day and that's not
just
for you but also for all the people on
your team
so
people want to come work somewhere where
they know that what they're doing has an
impact that's beyond just
like making a paycheck or like you know
solving some problem that isn't that
interesting like they want to have some
greater purpose in what they do and i
think that if you don't have something
in your brain turning like reinforcing
wire work
every single day then you're going to
get a very different culture out of that
than the one that you want and so
to illustrate that just a little bit
think about the companies that i've
worked at in the past
so alto vista actually back in 98.99 was
an incredibly mission-driven company
like everybody there was there to like
invent web search it had never really
been done before and there was this core
of people there who were as excited
about web search as like the core people
that you find at facebook today who are
you know crazy about connecting the
world and it was because they had this
idea that what had never been done
before they had this incredible sense of
purpose and it wasn't really until
you guys probably remember this this guy
rod trot came in to lead
um
alta vista and what he decided was they
weren't actually in the web search
business what they were in the business
of is competing with
lycos and excite and yahoo
you guys probably remember those those
companies and what happened was
instead of sticking to like what the
company was really about what people
were passionate about they got
sidetracked on this other thing and then
google came along and got
you know web search right and totally
ate their lunch right alta vista went
from like high riding in 99 to pretty
much out of business by early 2001
because of the rise of google now they
had no reason to lose that game at all
right although it was first they were
the first ones to do it they did it
really well
but they just got sidetracked they lost
sight of their vision and they tried to
get after something that wasn't like the
core of what they did
after that i worked at aol i challenged
anybody in the room to tell me what
aniwal's vision was
or is
it was the same for me when i worked
there and i went down on the netscape
campus and i remember that you know
nobody there was there from anything
more than you know having a attack job
you know like oh yeah i work in tech
i get paid every day and i have no idea
what this company is doing and i went
from it well
not directly but almost directly to
yahoo
and yahoo was interesting it was
there were all these different big
business units of yahoo and within those
business units like we're talking about
like hundred thousands of people in each
one of these things there was some sense
of mission and purpose within the unit
but there was no overall like what the
hell does this company do and you know
it's like the famous question like what
carol barts what is yahoo you know and
then she reads back a paragraph it's
really hard to get motivated and excited
as a company to go somewhere where you
can't answer that question so the
biggest thing i tell people i get asked
all the time like leaving yahoo after
such a long time
going to facebook what was the biggest
difference between those two places the
number one biggest difference was that
when you walked into facebook it was
immediately obvious that every single
person knew why they were there and
knows why they're there and like it
manifests in lots of different ways like
people can articulate what the vision of
the company is they think about how
their work ties to that company 80
of facebook is wearing a facebook
t-shirt on any given day that yahoo you
see like two or three on any given day
it's just a very close connection with
what's happening
every day so
the mission of facebook very clear
going to airbnb has been
a kind of similar experience where we
hire people who feel very connected to
the mission that we're doing as a
company because we want to have that
same feeling we want people to be there
for a reason and feel like they're doing
something bigger in the world and so why
am i even like talking about this stuff
with you guys right now you're all at
the beginning of some company that one
day will be you know the next google or
amazon or whatever
you can never start too early figuring
out like what you want your mission to
be and what kind of culture you want to
create around it like what your values
are and then reinforcing them now and
even hiring for them now because once it
gets away from you it's very hard to fix
it later on
this is a little bit of overwatch just
saying commission driven companies tend
to have great cultures you've got a
mission
you can build your culture around the
this is was my clear experience from
working at aol but
not knowing why you go to work every day
totally sucks
um
and maybe the best way to say this is as
you
think about building that culture
it's really important to bake into your
hiring so you have to think about what
matters to you like what are the values
that you uh subscribe to and that make
up your culture
and then don't hire people who don't fit
into it right and i say like don't hire
confident i mean that's easy
right like you don't hire people that
you don't want to work with but it's
also don't hire people who are competent
and good but just aren't a fit for your
company right there are some people out
there who are going to be great but they
really should be somewhere else they
shouldn't necessarily be
at your place
that's actually one of the hardest
decisions to make
when you've got somebody who's really
good you're desperate to hire people
there's so much like competition for
hiring and you've got somebody that you
know can do the job but you don't feel
like they're a fit like want to you know
have the same vision or values that you
do that's the hardest thing to say no to
but it's so important because
again
if you let this knuckle away from you
then later on you're yahoo and you're
trying to go
back and fix a culture that has been
broken for a long time
so
anyway i thought i'd share that stuff
you know having worked at a bunch of
these different places and seen a bunch
of different ones i don't know how many
people here have worked at
you know like google or
facebook
anybody that's two that's two people on
this audience all right not that many
okay
um
do you guys have any questions on the
culture stuff i'm gonna talk a little
bit about airbnb growth next but i mean
is this stuff that you hear all the time
or is this like these novel concepts
too yeah kind of curious about you said
80 percent of the people on facebook are
wearing the t-shirts i mean
um
why is that i guess i mean you said they
identified culture can you just maybe
expand a little bit because you think
that's all
naturally they all want to put their
t-shirts on do you think there's
actually
so the question is 80 of people at
facebook wear a facebook t-shirt every
day why is that well one because they
hand out a t-shirt about every five days
at facebook so you always have you
always have a new teacher that's one
piece of advice it's give out lots of
t-shirts but i think the other is that
people really identify with the company
you know i've been gone for almost a
year and i still carry around my
facebook bag right like it's something
that people feel very proud of they know
what the company is doing they feel like
it's doing something that's important in
the world and they identify with it so
why wouldn't you want to wear a you know
facebook t-shirt every day
then they're probably familiar with this
mark does q a
for 45 minutes or an hour every single
friday and what he'll do is at the
beginning of that like the whole company
is invited like you know more than a
thousand people tune in
every week and in the first 10 minutes
so let's sit there and talk about
whatever is on his mind and he'll tie
back the things that are on his mind to
whatever the most important things are
for the company and to how those things
like push forward the overall vision of
the company and this happens like every
single week and then it'll take 45
minutes of questions so there's like
this incredible sense of transparency
and repetition of here's what it is
we're working on and why we're doing it
i think that's been really valuable it's
something that we're trying to emulate
now with our team meetings at airbnb
because
as a company grows that problem of
communication and keeping people on the
same page gets
exponentially harder with that you know
every single person that you add
and so if you don't figure out like the
right games where people feel it's safe
to ask questions and they're getting a
constant reinforcement of what we're
working on they'll lose sight of it
um yeah i think facebook did a good job
with that other companies like the
strategy at yahoo was often
oh we'll have you know we'll have a
quarterly meeting and we'll
you know bring all the executives out on
stage and they'll explain to the company
here's what we're doing for the next
quarter the thing is that doing it once
every three months is just not nearly
enough for people to feel like they can
even ask questions in that forum or to
even remember
you know from the day that they work how
it ties back to what's happening at the
top also i mean i think the other
problem is they didn't really have a
great answer to the what is our vision
question
any other questions on this stuff
do all of your companies have like clear
visions and
values
yeah
one of the companies the starter
startups usually end up pivoting like
you start with the mission you're really
excited about it and then kind of change
you don't reach product market so you
have to switch something else sometimes
might be different from the original
thing
how should the company of the how should
the culture of the company
evolve
the question was what about early stage
companies that pivot
and i think yeah i think that
well i mean here's the thing if you're
going to pivot and the new direction is
not something that all of your team is
excited about or feels like they can
really get behind then you might lose
part of your team around that and that's
okay but maybe the answer there is that
you know at the beginning of a company
the values that you're looking for
people who are very versatile and who
feel
very excited about the nature of the
work not necessarily like maybe this
specific thing and so
maybe over time as you you know
establish your vision and the thing that
you're really going after then you start
hiring people who
attach directly to the vision as opposed
to like the nature of the work
that's off the cuff i haven't started a
company at this size before so i don't
know
should i start talking a little bit
about airbnb growth
yep right
so
um i'm just gonna voice over a few
slides that show uh
you know the growth of the company over
over a few years
um
but what you'll really see from this is
that
it took a long time to catch on like i
think that's probably the
that's probably like the core of the
story about airbnb is that it wasn't
overnight at all like people hear this
amazing story of all these people
traveling on everybody today but the
fact is that in the early years of the
company the only reason it got off the
ground is because like the founders and
small teams of people were going city by
city meeting with every single host in
that city like personally talking to
them about what hosting was and getting
them excited in the platform it took a
long time to get to critical mass to the
point where it became like a
self-sustaining uh growth
system and so what this visualization
shows is
the circles represent the number of
listings in different cities in 2009 and
so the only city that had more than a
thousand listings in 2009 was new york
city here
by the way i was looking at this does
anybody know where that is
wait i heard like eight answers does
anybody know which one that is
denver
all right cool i'm gonna confirm that
later i couldn't figure out which city
that was uh illinois new york san
francisco los angeles so that's kind of
where we were in the beginning
the growth ramp was pretty incredible so
2010 you can see that we
started getting into lots of different
cities in the world
um very small presence though that's
every one of those blue dots is only 50
to 100 listings and what we found is
that
once somebody has traveled to one of the
cities right like once somebody has gone
to new york or gone to san francisco
they've stayed with a host and had a
great experience they go back to where
they came from and they're like
hey i could probably make some money
doing this so they go ahead and list
their property but the problem is that
when
you've only got two or three places
listed in a city then you've got a
chicken and egg marketplace problem
right like there's no inventory there to
search for so why would anybody search
for it so they don't get any demand so
why would they list their property and
so the way that we really grew in all
these different places is that we
did targeted ways to generate demand on
the market through like online marketing
campaigns running campaigns on facebook
and google and by going on the ground
different cities to get more hosts
involved to host meetups like meet
people individually make sure they stay
on the site
basically to the point where in any city
that we get past
100 listings now we've got a pretty
predictable growth curve so by the time
you've got 100 listings and we can
generate some demand to your market it's
it grows very predictably from that
point out if for anything less than 100
listings it's kind of
like we have to invest some time to make
sure that the market can get off the
ground
so that's what is that that's the 2010
slide
in 2011 you can see that it's starting
to get into the other parts of the world
very big in europe
and started getting into south um south
america
and then 2000 so and then it was really
2012 that the thing totally took off so
you can see that
every view is now in
well over 10 000 cities
actually might even be more like 15 000
cities um instead 192 countries and the
point i'm trying to make with this is
just that
the growth part at the beginning was
very very manual but you had to like get
the engine started through manual work
and as soon as like the manual work had
been done then the network effects of
the business started taking over and
things really spread a little bit
crazily and what we'll get into in a
minute is that operating in this many
countries creates a pretty interesting
payments problem since we're in between
the payments transaction but i'll get to
that in a minute
um just to give you another sense of the
ramp up
so in the first
about four years
it took about four years for airbnb to
get to its first four million guests on
the platform
um but you can see that as it took off
in the last
year it only took us a few months to get
to the next four million like on the on
the growth and it's because of that
it's because that chicken and egg
problem is out of the way right like now
we've got significant inventory in all
these different markets
and we've got enough because we've got
enough inventory we get enough demand
there's somewhere that you can stay in
that market so people will search to go
stay there and so the ramp just like
you know it's really taking off it's
gone a long way since this slide was
created too
um
this is just a fun stat so i'm going to
show it
right now we have
on any given night we have about 150 000
people staying in airbnbs around the
world
so it's getting to the point where
you know we have about 150 000 people
staying every night we have
over half a million places listed on
airbnb
we don't really like to compare
ourselves with hotels because it's a
very different type of travel experience
than we get but if you take like a
hilton or somebody like that they have a
little bit more than 600 000 rooms in
hilton so we're getting
to the point where in terms of like
available space we're getting close to
some of the biggest hotel chains um in
the world
now our occupancy rates aren't as high
as the hilton so we've got a little work
to do on that on that side
the last thing i'll show on growth is
you know just
some visualization of the first few
thousand trips that happened on airbnb
and the point here again is that the
growth of our business has really come
from the network effects of somebody
goes and travels here there's an
incredible you know
web of uh travel where you know from any
city there's probably like outbound
destinations or people coming in from
destinations where everybody hadn't
started yet and that travel experience
created the network effect that planet
got people to host and lots of different
uh cities around the world so that was
kind of the fuels autograph different
companies have different problems around
this right like if you're
if you're uber you get the advantage of
word of mouth like people say uber's
awesome but the fact is if you want to
go into a new city you need to like send
in a ground team and get a bunch of cars
and like do a manual setup process there
we're kind of lucky that because
individuals can set themselves up this
way they can go back and start getting
things off the ground without us
necessarily needing to go into every
single city
do you guys have any other questions
about growth i can tell you you know
more about like some specific tactics
and things that we've used or anything
problems that you guys are facing now
yeah how did you guys deal with i guess
copycats in other countries where you
might not be able to you know protect
your ip
questions around copycats
um
and there are still many out there
but probably the
probably the worst copycat situation
that we ever had was do
you ever heard of one dude
yeah yeah two three hands four hands all
right
i'd rather you already very wimpy was
actually this incredible thing they went
out and raised
i think close to two hundred million
dollars to compete with us like to agree
with everybody back when airbnb really
wasn't that big especially in europe and
they they raised all this money they
spent all this money on advertising and
our response to that
they say our response to that is before
i joined the company but you know
airbnb's response to that at the time
was we actually created 11 offices
around the world with ground teams that
could go around market by market and
make sure that we weren't losing
inventory to wim do we cut down on the
scrapers like they were trying to scrape
our listings and like add them to our
site we put in a whole bunch of
preventative stuff
to not allow that and we really just
doubled down overseas where we thought
where we thought we were weak and where
one moved it was strong
and uh ultimately they couldn't catch us
so they
and this is sort of like the great thing
about a marketplace is that once you
have that engine going like you've got
supply and demand
um satisfied and balanced out well
enough it's very hard to compete with
that marketplace it's like why isn't
there another
ebay out there except for you know maybe
in china
um
where there are other competitive
reasons
yeah oh yeah i have a different question
so like could you get a little bit more
in depth on how airing b commits like
the first 50 people to let strangers
stay in their home and just
like uh just how do you guys
so the question is how did
how did airbnb get the first 50 people
like this very first initial customer
base yeah
well it's hard for me to tell too much
of the story because i wasn't there at
the time but i can tell you what i've
heard uh secondhand which is really that
um
in the early days they were actually in
yc right and they got the advice it
turned out that most of the hosts they
were in san francisco right and brian
joe and nate were in san francisco
most of the hosts were actually in new
york and they got the advice from paul
graham at the time he's like why are you
here when the only people that matter to
your entire company are in new york you
should go to new york and they did they
went out to new york they stayed there
for multiple months and all they did was
host
meetups like get people together they
would go have individual meetings with
every host to like address their
concerns and figure out things that
could be a problem and basically just
get them engaged so it was a total
ground game in new york when airbnb was
getting off the ground and it wouldn't
have like i don't think it would have
grown at all had they not done that i
think that it probably like because it
was such a
like strange concept they would let
somebody come stay in your house i think
that they had to be like
literally hand to hand with these people
to get them
to the beginning but then once you know
you see enough people doing it you reach
that critical mass point then other
people are like well it can't be all bad
there's 20 000 people doing it in new
york
did was there
i mean there must have been some
hesitancy also from the guests
as well were there guest meetups were
there guest explanations
uh we i think that they mostly
concentrated on the host and it's
actually it's kind of strange but um
demand has almost never been our problem
okay in the system like there are times
when demand is the problem like when it
gets into it is low season but almost
from the beginning there's been more
demand than there is supply
in the system so we're often just
like solving for getting more hosts onto
the platform so that we can meet demand
when we get into
uh into peak season i think the reason
for that is probably that you know it's
a cheaper way to travel like you can it
doesn't have to be like you can go
pretty high end on airbnb but if you
want to get a deal like it's um that
could be a little bit less expensive way
to do it um
and yeah i guess i guess we're a little
less worried than hooks
there's a lot of groundwork going on but
when after it started doing critical
mass were there certain things you ran
into and how did you deal with those
bottlenecks sure the question is how did
you deal with scale
especially like ramping up hosts like
getting close to the point where they're
they have a good listing and everything
else this is part of the story i didn't
tell in the first 50 hose but i should
have because it's cool
is that
one of the early things airbnb did is
they made it look like they had a way to
get professional photography for your
home so like if you're listening your
space interview like earn more money by
having better photos we've got this
whole photography program but the
reality is the only thing behind the
photography program was brian and joe so
what they would do is when you signed up
for the photography program brian and
joe would show up in your house with a
camera and take pictures of your house
and then put that on the listing so that
like when you think about ground game
it's like you know about as much of a
ground game as you can run
but what they did after that was they
figured out this is something that's you
know high demand if you want to you know
earn a lot of money off of your place
then you better have high quality photos
and so what they did is actually open it
up to
independent photographers so now when
you request photography on your site
we'll automatically connect you to a
photographer in your area and schedule
the time to come out take the photo for
you i think now we work with something
like four or five thousand independent
photographers out there that go and you
know take good photos of listings and we
will take listings down if they don't
have uh if they don't have great photos
or if they don't have full descriptions
we're actually trying to get even more
strict about cost standards so that like
you can't have a crappy site or a crappy
listing on airbnb we want it to be a
high quality experience yeah how do you
uh
use this network
yeah we'll do um
um
we'll do some things around like
we'll do a big push to get more hosts
onto the platform so like we'll run a
big like online marketing campaign
facebook ads google other things that
are really concentrated at host and
we'll do that usually in the um
in the low season the low travel season
so like trying to build supply and like
we're really kind of entering the low
season for travel right now given where
the majority of our business is today
and so but as we start ramping up to
that high season again we'll switch it
around and try to just like fill the
supply with um demand for the guest side
so we'll run a whole bunch of stuff when
you're searching for hotels or travel or
anything else then you'll find everybody
listening to go fill up all those places
so that's that's one way that we kind of
balance like how do you grow the supply
side and then fill it with demand on the
other side
in terms of just like the straight
network effect um
when somebody returns from a trip so
like they went and traveled somewhere
and they come back from a trip they're a
guest and they look like the right
profile person we'll hit them like the
right type of person
we'll hit them with things on the airbnb
homepage encouraging them to become a
host so we actually do a lot of stuff to
try to convert travelers into hosts
right at the time when they come back
and like we'll we'll cater that
specifically like we will only show them
that if they rated the trip five stars
so it's like only if they had an awesome
trip on the platform will we try to
convince them to become a host but you
know good percentage of all of our trips
are five stars so we got a lot of
opportunity to target
yeah
um question specific tactic i see you
using
um sometimes you try to log into airbnb
for a while
uh right away you send me
an email
awesome contest or something like that
um what's the logic feature like that
the question is right after i log into
airbnb i get i haven't logged in for a
while after i've been logged in for a
while so yeah instead take a trip i go
to the side so at that point i'm on the
site i'm engaged yeah but then you still
send me an email right away
well i could be totally honest with you
i didn't know that we did that
what is the in the content of the of the
email
um some like contests or it seems like
an engagement like a kind of thing i
should get if i haven't logged in for a
while yeah but i get it right when i log
in i always wonder if there's
some thinking
no actually if anything we're thinking
about doing exactly the other thing what
you would expect is if you were
so the question is about like the timing
of some of the emails like the
engagement emails that we um sent to
people on every week
um
if anything we're thinking about going
the other direction which is if you have
traveled on the platform before you had
a great experience you know maybe about
six months later we might send you an
email again to say maybe it's time to go
on another on another trip um so it
sounds like maybe there's a
broken trigger there or something i'll
look into that when i get back
uh maybe one more and then i want to
talk a bit about payments you guys have
another culture question as it relates
to you know the beginning it was a lot
of kind of elbow grease and making it
work
and now that it is working how do you
keep that culture going that you can't
just sit back and let the product sell
itself
the question is um how do you keep the
culture going when
you know it was very entrepreneurial
beginning like a lot of hand to hands
and little stuff how do you maintain
that over time and i think you know what
i was trying to talk about earlier with
culture was you know you have to figure
out
what we call like our core values at
airbnb like what are the things that we
value in every employee that we bring in
and then figure out how to actually
interview for that in a way that gives
you the right signals so like
something like for example one of the
core values that we have is be a serial
entrepreneur
and what that refers to is
there was a time when everybody was
basically out of money they didn't have
any funding they were maxing out credit
cards and the way that they got
themselves through was they came up like
brian joe and nate came up with this
thing where they created cereal boxes
this was like during the obama campaign
they came up with like obama owners and
mccain flakes
did anybody see that yeah yeah all right
a couple people and then they sold these
things and that generated enough like in
this moment of desperation that
generated enough money that they could
like kind of keep things going but so
one of the questions that we ask people
or like one of the areas that we
interview for and the core value
interviews that every single person goes
through
is questions related to that like serial
entrepreneurship when is the time that
you've failed at something and then
figured out a way to pull yourself out
of it
and then there's some other values that
we
uh interview for as well like
you know for us in our business like one
of the things that we care about is that
everybody is a good host and that
doesn't mean that they're necessarily
hosting on airbnb but they have the
values of somebody who knows how to host
somebody
and put themselves in other people's
shoes
we care about being very detail-oriented
so we have this other value that we call
every frame matters meaning like every
frame of the trip if you can think about
the trip in a series of like
storyboarded frames every single one of
those frames matters and we interview
for people who have that level of detail
we like being detail-oriented so i think
it's really about like if you want you
have to define what it is that you're
trying to maintain in order to maintain
it define what your core values are
figure out if you know a way to
interview for them that actually gives
you signal on whether these people are
matched with your values and then
hold yourself to it
okay
i'm going to skip into the next one
talk a little bit about payments
um
i think that even before i get to the
payments lives i think that this slide
actually
illustrates a little bit of the
complexity of the payments problem that
we have like we're operating in so many
different countries
that have so many different weird rules
around payments and many different
currencies and everything else that
we've had to do a lot of work to make
that possible
um
and probably the best way to
talk about it is the problem that we're
trying to solve so
in the beginning
this is not anyway back in the beginning
when airbnb first started we didn't even
accept payments so like it wasn't it was
really just about connecting guests and
hosts at the beginning it wasn't about
us being a payments platform which is
interesting because you think about it
at the beginning of everybody maybe
there wasn't that much of a business
model
um because payments turned out to be
pretty essential to the business model
um
but the only reason that we came on it
and decided to do it was because we
wanted to solve a problem and the
problem was you know it goes back to a
story where brian was staying with a
host
and
he had been there for a day
and at the end of the first day the host
was like hey you know
you know where's my money
and brian's like oh i totally forgot to
pay you i'll go to the atm later and get
your money then he comes back he stays
that night and the next day he forgets
again
and after that it wasn't like a nice
where's my money it was more of like a
dude get out of my house
you know where's my money and that's
like a um
you know
pretty awkward situation right and so
what they realized is
if we actually started accepting and
remitting the payments for this then you
kind of move this whole awkward thing
completely out of the way and up front
so it's handled before you even get into
the process of the transaction and so it
can make it much more seamless so it
became obvious to them at that moment
that like
there's no way this is going to work
unless we start handling the payment so
that's where the payment stuff started
um
let's talk a little bit just about like
the evolution so again at the beginning
there were no payments
um then we started accepting u.s credit
cards that you could pay with a credit
card makes sense
we realized that that was great for us
but for the rest of the world we needed
something else um so we started
leveraging paypal for international so
you could you know pay with paypal and
get paid out with paypal um and then we
started adding support for international
cards and so for both u.s and
international you know branch has been
one of the partners that we've worked
with on that as well as world pay
and then if you go to the
other side so like this is a two-sided
marketplace right so you have to accept
payments for people you take their money
and they hold it for a good time until
they go on the trip and then when
they're one day into their trip we pay
off to the host so then there's the
payout side in the beginning obviously
there were no paths
then we started using paypal because it
was you know the best solution or the
only solution that was out there at the
time
and then we started getting into like a
more complicated stuff
around like doing direct bank transfers
um
in the us
and then we also started doing um
international bank transfers
and western union i think western union
is kind of funny because you don't think
about like
being a host and
i'm gonna go down to the western union
and pick up my cash but it turns out
that in south america and particularly
in argentina this was like super
important they didn't want to get paid
any other way the way they want to get
paid is like in cash so
we implemented western union and in the
first month we did i think about like a
hundred thousand dollars in volume that
has increased like more than 20 x since
then of people who just want to go to
the western union and get their cash
that's kind of funny it's really popular
in south america and now
um we're kind of
working on some other things that are
and maybe i'll talk about this a little
bit and like the conclusion side but
some other things that are like
different payout methods that right now
might represent like a very small slice
of the total payment volume but might be
capping our growth like by not having
those payout methods it might be that
we're not able to grow more in another
part of the world
so let's show like the overall payment
stack um so this is like how we take
payments in there's us our entry huge
amount of our volume goes through great
tree for payments we still use paypal
those go through the processors and then
into our
into our bank accounts
which i'm told we have many
um
and then on the other side
you know airbnb's bank account
the same thing i was talking about
before but like would do direct deposit
a lot of posts really like that because
the money just shows up in their account
a very small western union for people
who want to go to the store and pick up
their money um and then paypal for
people who want cash to bank accounts
and then we're sort of starting to
experiment with these other things like
these other uh payment methods we've
tried
we did a couple integrations recently
and this is like tiny volume on the on
the whole but like
um accu-link and uh payoneer which do
like prepaid debit cards which is
another thing that where there's some
demand like you get paid out by somebody
sending you a prepaid debit card and a
pin number so you can go spend money
that way
actually
yeah l y n k
um
so again just talking about the
complexity of the problem um right now
we're collect money we'll accept payment
32 currencies and we'll pay out at 65.
and so what it means is that
in the total number of ways that money
can flow through currency wise there's
over a thousand different combinations
and those thousand different
combinations actually happen because
people do travel to every single
possible combination of ways that you
can go around the world so a lot of what
we do is around
making sure that we have enough coverage
of the payment and payout methods that
we can actually like serve everyone in a
way that feels native like it doesn't we
can't get it 100 all all the time but we
get as close to giving somebody a native
feeling experience and native currency
as possible and then we have to apply
all the foreign exchange rate stuff on
top of that so we accept payment
significant in a lot of cases up to 30
days before the actual trip happens in
that time the exchange rates change we
have to make sure that we do
the appropriate exchange rate conversion
before we do the payout
and then
on top of that we have to make sure
and it sounds like an obvious thing but
it's actually really complicated is we
have to reconcile
every single line of transaction that we
have in our database like every payment
that we do
all the way to the bank that actually
deposits the money in somebody's account
to make sure that what we think we're
paying out is actually what's being paid
out which turns out to be
a uh
imperfect science in that we'll have
like on any given day we'll have a few
hundred of those that we have to go
through manually one by one and figure
out exactly what you know where do the
line items line up so it's a
you know famously pretty funny problem
i keep thinking my down is arrow's to
work um and then like the last point
here is that
you know for those currencies they're
actually serving you know again 192
countries that um that we're operating
in today
yeah especially um the reconciliation
what's happening there was the problem
that's just making sure that like
banks don't have
the cleanest interfaces right now and so
what we do is like we
um you know we'll send you know
information like this needs to be paid
out by this bank the bank needs to
deposit the money into this account and
then after the fact we'll go through
some strange interface where we'll like
download a csv file from the bank that
has every transaction that happened for
us and we'll put that normalize that
data and then reconcile that against
what we told the bank to do to make sure
that if anything gets missed in between
like any payment got missed in between
that we have a record of it and we can
go figure it out like we can reconcile
it this is important just for our own
financial accounting but also to make
sure that if anything gets lost in that
loop that we don't uh leave money on
them
maintain whatever happens
there's problems with manual error then
you're saying
yeah or it could be or it could be
system error it could be fraud we deal
with a lot of chargeback fraud that's
one of the things i'll say in the
takeaway slide is as the volume of money
that you deal with gets bigger the
number of bad guys also gets bigger like
people who are attempting to
just steal from you
is there another question yeah so
do you have to
report
uh government tax
forms in 192 countries for people who
take in money
we don't handle this perfectly in every
country right now but we do
we do give out tax forms to all u.s
hosts and we also claim that which is
this
variable occupancy tax that is uh
important in europe
but we don't cover every single tax law
in every single country yet like
obviously that would be a lot of
work but so what we're trying to do is
like cover the ones that are the biggest
uh issues right now like the biggest
countries that are worried about it and
like we'll keep working our way out to
the rest of the countries
this is going to take a long time right
it's going gonna take a long time to get
all that exactly right but um at the
moment we give every single us host um
the tax forms that they need to pay
taxes on the income that they earn uh
while histamine on airbnb
yeah do you also deal with uh
we do we actually have a in-house risk
team
and what the wrist team does is identify
patterns of like chargeback fraud
account takeovers money laundering
like money laundering is one of those
things that sounds very james bondy but
people really do use systems like this
to
money launder and so we have things that
we can use to try to algorithmically
detect that kind of behavior and then
put so basically we do is we have
algorithms that will detect behavior
that look like fraud or look like money
laundering sure two different kinds of
fraud and then those get kicked out to a
manual queue and we have
agents that look at all those items to
make sure that they're either good or
bad
yeah how do you keep track of like uh
countries that like the us government
won't like
do business in iran
the question is how do we keep track of
countries that the us government won't
let us do business
yeah well we don't do business in iran
right now is the way that we've dealt
with that one i don't think that we have
too many other
places where we're not allowed to
operate right now we had um
we have one country that we weren't
operating in for the wrong reasons that
we opened up recently
and it was fine but um yeah we're not
doing business in iran right now what
about places that are just dangerous is
there any exposure to airbnb
or like
you know from the traveler's perspective
you send them into like some political
hot spot or somewhere where there's a
lot of violence from you yeah we don't
really get into that like in terms of
personal insurance or anything like
we're you know we're in the business of
connecting travelers with with hosts i
think when it comes to personal
liability it's kind of on the individual
to make sure that they're not putting
themselves in harm's way right like this
is why we have travel advisories that go
out to everyone um what we do do is
insurance for hosts to make sure that
like if a guest behaves poorly or you
know causes some kind of issue with the
house or whatever we have a guarantee
like we have the you know airbnb million
dollar guarantee if something bad
happens to your house then uh that's
like insurance for you to make sure that
it can be repaired but in terms of
traveling to hot spots and things like
that like for personal liability it's on
the individual
when you go on travel
i always stay in interviews everywhere i
go and actually it's a little
funny so i was just a grace hopper
conference
a few weeks ago and we got
three airbnb houses and we all stayed
and it was super fun
yeah i'm actually also a pretty regular
post on airbnb we try to make it so that
like
you know people don't travel all the
time but you can be hosting all the time
so we um we give people incentives to
travel and then we also try to
incentivize people to be hosts
themselves because if you don't use the
product it's hard to know what it's like
who you are when you travel what's that
like do they know that there's a big wig
from
airbnb sitting on their couch i think
most hosts don't really think about that
they probably wouldn't think that i'm a
big wig they'd probably think like oh
hey some dude who works at your movies
i'm gonna stay at my house it'd be
interesting like oh you should put this
button on your site you know like to
have this like filtered out
oh we actually we did that like three
weeks ago we did a host meet up in
sorry mr man like over a month ago now
we did a host meet up in new york with
50 of our top posts in new york like
people who have like the highest
occupancy rates and it was an evening of
that i had like my notes out all night
and i was just writing down like every
single complaint they had about the site
and it was so funny like some of these
people are like so engaged they were
like what i want is a way that i can
download um to excel a file of everybody
who stayed in my place and how long they
stayed so that i could do metrics on how
to increase my occupancy rates
i was like all right dude
that's obviously a keeper
the other thing that i found is that um
there are a fair number of people in new
york who are interested in
like hosts in new york and this is
around the world but this is the stories
that i got from new york who are
interested in helping other people be
hosts so like even if you don't have
enough time to manage your calendar
manage availability and everything else
there are other hosts we're interested
in just helping property manage your
place so that you can earn some money
from it and maybe they take a cut from
it it's kind of interesting like some
other business models that are
being created on top of this stuff
yeah so
connecting the scale
just sort of the technical scale earlier
versus and also then this legal scale
right so
if you have to give people 1099 when did
you decide to do that like was that
something that you know what we know is
going to be people must do from the
beginning or did that something dawn on
you how to decide to navigate when to
navigate these things that uh that was
not something that we did from the
beginning and it did dawn on us after
when it was pointed out to us by a
regulator that this would be income
earned and we really need to think about
that and i think the
you know the founders were kind of like
oh yeah taxes
went back and started figuring it out at
this point the way that we're dealing
with it is that um
you know it's about
the regulatory issues are very
complicated around this for taxes and
for everything else what we're trying to
do is just address things in terms of
like the scale where we're operating so
try to solve for the tax problems in the
biggest markets that we're operating in
understand what it is that the local
governments really want to get out of it
and make sure that we're solving for
them and also solving for our hosts on
the platform like
it sometimes can be a little
you know without going too far off here
it can be a little
hard to tell
between what a host wants and what a
government wants and whether they're
always you know in line with each other
so we try to walk the balance as best we
can do you wait until there's a problem
you know as you're scaling you wait
there's a problem absolutely the trigger
you try to
how do you navigate that scaling the
question is do we wait until until
there's a problem uh we definitely don't
we're trying to be very proactive about
that working with local governments and
you know satisfying their needs and
satisfying the needs of us we're not we
don't want to sit around and wait until
we get in trouble and then
uh you know and then do the right thing
i think that we want to be very
proactive about it i mean like we want
airbnb to be operating above ford uh
everywhere in the world it should be
yeah kind of piggybacking off that
question a little bit you guys have a
lot of like legal issues in new york and
i think san francisco when you guys
started out with
just the regulations regarding hotel and
stuff like that
uh when did that come about and how are
you guys dealing with it how did you
guys deal with that yeah i don't want to
go into too much depth on on this
particular topic because things are a
little hot in new york right now i don't
know if you guys have seen like the
recent stuff that's going on
what i'll say is that we are trying to
take a very hard stand against giving up
our users data and our host data in new
york for
what we believe is more of a phishing
expedition by the new york justice
system than like actually targeting bad
behavior on the platform and so we're
taking a pretty hard stand against that
stuff right now which i personally feel
great about i think it's the right thing
to do uh for people who are just like
earning some extra income off of their
own use space
but it's a complex issue so i don't want
to get like too far
down the path today
could you talk a little bit about
partnership
with airlines it wasn't anything like
that the question is were there any
partnerships that helped us grow um well
i mean not to be too pandering or
anything but i mean having a huge amount
of
like payments is this really complicated
problem having partners that were able
to
we were able to leverage to solve that
problem like partners like braintree was
a huge deal like just getting that
problem off the table and letting us
focus on the problem of travel and not
the problem of payments was
a really big deal another partnership
that seems obvious but i'll call it out
anyway it's aws right like we've been
built on aws from from the very
beginning and at the scale that we
operate at
that has been a huge problem set like
managing all the servers and
infrastructure that we haven't had to
devote huge mind share to instead we've
been able to concentrate on the problem
that's unique to us
all right i'm just going to cut to my
last slide then we can do more questions
um
so i just wanted to give like a few
takeaways i hope this stuff is useful
for you guys but like uh
from payments one is that you know
everybody back at the beginning was
working in an environment where there
weren't a lot of great companies that
were available to to do this stuff like
brain three was
much earlier in the cycle than it is
right now paypal is good for something
it's not good for others like it was
hard to get negotiate good rates
today there's a lot of really good
providers for this i would say if you
don't need to solve the payments problem
for your specific use case like try to
leverage your partner for this stuff
right now you can get really good rates
um i made this point already but as the
more volume of money moves through your
system lots of scary behavior will
emerge like you'll find a lot of bad
actors who are trying to defraud you and
scale money from you it happens to us
every single day there's people trying
to get
um
you know get at the money they're trying
to take over people's accounts they're
trying to change payout information and
do bad things to steal money
depending on whether you're in the us or
international people's payment
preferences i talked about this a little
bit of like western union in argentina
like preferences are very different like
the way people want to pay and get paid
is not like everybody doesn't use credit
card and want to direct bank transfer
like people have different opinions so
depending on what market you're going
after you have to really cater to that
uh to that place
um let's see i talked a little bit about
this it's not always obvious when you
add a new provider like it's a chicken
and egg problem you might not it might
not represent a lot of your volume today
but it might also be copying your growth
because people you know they really want
to go to western union if you don't have
western union maybe they're not going to
use your site right
we talked a little bit about
bank reconciliation and foreign exchange
and the last thing is um
don't just round everything up
which is
i'm not sure if i'm supposed to talk
about this but
back in the early days to make it easy
we decided that we were going to round
everything up so everything is stored in
whole dollar amounts in airbnb's back
end today which it turns out when you
get into taxes
it's really complicated because taxman
cares all the way down to the penny so
that's my final piece of parting advice
is don't just round everything up
you said whole dollars
yeah we'll round up to the dollar one
dollar two dollars yeah
that's it more questions
go to somebody who hasn't asked a
question before do you have one
no okay um so all right are you seeing
any kind of response or what's happening
with hotels and
other providers that you're kind of
competing with because you're bringing
all this new inventory
i think that we've we've stayed like a
little bit out of
hotel tour for stuff like we really
position ourselves differently from
hotels and they obviously care about it
but we have not tried to do any like
head-to-head
combat with hotels one thing that i
think is interesting or an interesting
statistic about everybody that i'll
share is that
more than 30 of all of our travel
happens outside of a place that has a
major hotel chain so we're actually like
kind of expanding the category of travel
and it makes sense i actually had a
family stay with me a few months ago and
they came and stayed in my place in palo
alto and the reason they stayed with me
instead of staying at the hotel down the
street is because they could walk from
my house to the to their grandkids who
they were visiting and so you think
about that use case times quite a bit it
can give you something that's like much
more local and outside of where they're
even where people make sense of how you
tell them
coming to you or partnerships or if
they're
doing any kind of moves that are like
legally just virtue or
i mean there's certainly like a hotel
lobby that wants us to be more regulated
but we haven't really gone head to head
to them
yeah going back to
the marketing discussion you had earlier
do you have any idea this is before you
retire what were
the different marketing channels that
worked best for them was it seo
yeah
the question is what are the like
highest value or highest roi marketing
channels would be a good way to say it
um
by far the highest
roi and marketing channel that we have
today and i think it's always been this
case is uh google ads so inserts you've
got like high intent we get um you know
great click-through rates on those ads
it makes sense people are searching for
travel they get an airbnb listing um we
advertise at that point and they click
through uh facebook is not bad but it's
not uh nearly to that level right now i
apologize to my former employer
and uh seo has been important but it
hasn't been as much of a driver as the
uh as the pay campaigns that we've done
i think there's actually a lot more that
we can do with seo than we do today
the question is about the growth team
and when did we start organizing that
yeah
we actually look for people who
the question is how do we build it and
how do we find and hire people for that
team
we started i think that they started the
concept of a growth team before i got
there in the beginning of the year i
tried to like make it a more defined
thing because i wanted to bring some of
that across from the facebook growth
team
we find and hire people
uh who
have to be like strong journalists you
don't necessarily have to have a
background in growth to be a good growth
engineer but we also find people who are
really motivated by data it's like a
different mindset of it like you
if you're if
what you're really excited about is
being able to go home and you know tell
your mom and your friends like i built
this thing check it out you might not be
a great fit for the growth team you'll
be a great fit for the growth team if
you're like i ran this experiment and
increased conversion by four percent and
that's gonna yield you know x million
more or whatever down the line like that
like try to find people who fit that
mindset and get excited about that kind
of work
which i think is the last questions
cool what's your biggest engineering
challenge
biggest engineering challenge i think
that um you know we've talked a bunch
about payments and other things i think
that the biggest challenge that we'll
have in the next year is
um
around matching and like the algorithmic
side of that like how do we make it so
that
every single time you search on airbnb
you're successful so like i want to find
a place every single time you should
find a place and it should be easy but
it shouldn't be this like exhaustive
eight-hour searching process it should
be that like the top five places that
you're going to want to stay are there
recommended to you right away and we can
do that for users who are on the site
because we've got their past searching
behavior and we can do it for new users
who come in because we can like
cross-reference them to other people
who've done similar searches before and
just get them the best recommendations
but i think that that matching problem
and turning that into something where
um every single time somebody searches
on airbnb they end up successful and
having a listing is probably one of the
biggest challenges that we have over the
next year
one question one last thing what's next
what are you guys gonna do to get
innovative what's next for airbnb what's
next for airbnb oh there's so many ways
to answer that question um
the big things that we're working on
right now is we're getting it so that
you can do everything you need to do on
airbnb as a host on the mobile apps what
we're finding is this is a huge
percentage of all of our hosts use the
mobile apps primarily and now we're just
like building all the functionality that
we need for that to be like awesome and
seamless and then as we get into next
year the big thing is going to be around
matching and conversion like getting
like i was talking about there like
getting people perfectly matched making
it a seamless booking experience um
if you get a little bit longer term
airbnb is about more than just like the
place you're going to sleep at everybody
should be about the entire travel
experience right so one day we want it
to be end to end like every single step
along the way on that trip airbnb is
with you like removing friction from the
trip making it easier so like so like
you book something but you know you walk
up to the front door and the door
automatically unlocks you walk in and
you know
everybody automatically pulls up like
the places that have great takeout next
to there in case you want to get a meal
like every step along the way we can be
making the trip more effortless and i
think that that's like down the line
that's where we want to get to
thanks again guys